lesal c'est peut-être un théâtre de
plein air le plus grand du monde où s
côtoie tout le tous les travailleurs dal
et ben vous y rencontrez les hommes en
fraac en habit de belles femmes en
toilettes de soirée depuis le Moyen-âge
en fait il y a un marché sur cet espace
des marché à vrai dire quand on parle
desal de Paris on parle avant tout des
albaltar c'est-à-dire un ensemble de
pavillons qui ont été construits à
partir des années
1850 10 pavillons à la fin du 19e siècle
alors d'immenses pavillons parce que
l'ensemble couvrait environ 33 haares et
des pavillons qui étaient spécialisés
c'est dans différentes marchandises
différentes danrées à minuit la vie
commence les premiers des quelques
milliers de camions qui forment l'armada
des central arrivent avec leur
chargement c'est le début d'un
gigantesque encombrement qui ne
s'ordonnera qu'avec le
jour l'état de légumes jonche le carreau
en attendant les enchères une animation
égale règne dans les pavillons dont le
plus actif et sans doute le plus
spectaculaire est celui de la boucherie
puisqu'il y passe l'avant-veille de Noël
quelques 1800 tonnes de viande pour
reprendre l'expression de Zola c'est le
Ventre de Paris romand Zola qui date de
1873 le Ventre de Paris c'est-à-dire que
c'est là que Paris s'approvisionnait une
ville énorme et surpeuplée va reprendre
une chasse qui jamais ne s'arrête la
chasse au pain quotidien et c'était un
monde à part c'était un des grands
visages du Paris popul
donc là on est rue du Pont Neuf j'allais
dire devant une institution c'est-à-dire
le chien qui fume restaurant qui a
peut-être été ouvert au début du 20e
siècle et dont la façade est inscrite au
monument historique depuis les années 80
et qui représente bah justement les
chiens qui fument et puis ce qu'on
pouvait consommer justement au Hal j'ai
envie dire les les grandes nourritures
traditionnelles que mangeent tous ceux
qui il fréquentait ce type
d'établissement à partir du moment où se
développe les halall et peut-être même
avant il y a finalement deux publics qui
enre ces bistro ces restaurants enfin
bistro on parlait pas encore de bistro
on en pas on parle de bistro la toute
fin du du 19e siècle il y a un public
euh j'allais dire local tous ceux qui
travaillent ici les fordal bien sûr et
puis la myriade
d'employés et puis plus tard à partir du
20e siècle les camionneurs les
transporteurs et puis il y a les No
ça c'est tout à fait attesté de manière
claire dès le milieu du 19e siècle c'est
des gens qui vont souvent dans d'autres
restaurant qui font la fête qui boivent
qui vont au théâtre et qui en fin de
nuit viennent
ici c'est peut-être un théâtre de plein
air le plus grand du monde ou si côtoi
tout le tous les travailleurs des ou si
côtoi les monde de la viande des légumes
et chose bizarre et chose curieuse c'est
que ces gens qui sont des travailleurs
ne font aucune attention à toute la
société des gens qui viennent après au
sortir de l'opéra à la sortie des
théâtres de différentes manifestations
ben vous y rencontrez les hommes en frac
en habit de belles femmes en toilettes
de soirée au contact de ces gens-là qui
ne portent aucune attention tout ça
c'est c'est c'est la vie
constanteal alors là on est devant le
pied de cochon qu'on peut présenter je
crois
comme l'établiss
qui aujourd'hui semble le plus associé à
la restauration autour des halles donc
il est quand même réellement porteur de
cette mémoire ça c'est
incontestable ce qu'on trouve dans ces
restaurants des h c'est une nourriture
assez simple généralement une nourriture
assez viandarde aussi c'est que le pied
de cochon c'est un bon exemple on a des
on a des menus des années 30 par exemple
on voit qu'on trouve du Pied de Cochon
préparé sous différentes formes mais
encore une fois une carte assez simple
assez limité il est difficile de parler
de spécialité parisienne il y a la
gratindéal si on veut c'est tout le
statut d'une spécialité c'est tout le
problème elle n'a rien de spécial cette
gratinée donc ce qui compte plus c'est
pas tant que il n'y a qu'à Paris qu'on
fasse cette soupe c'est qu'elle est
devenue un symbole un emblème de cette
cuisine qui se faisait dans le quartier
quand on parle Paris et cuisine on pense
haute cuisine grande cuisine mais c'est
aussi la cuisine des bistr la cuisine
des petits restaurants et justement
l'imagine
entour les h c'est aussi cet imaginaire
là dès les années 30 on parle de
déménager les hall ce n'est qu'un au
revoir et pourtant non c'est un adieu
toute la semaine les chevillards les
bouchers en gros ont pris le petit
dernier sur les comptoirs de la rue
coquillère avant de partir pour
s'installer à r des images et un
folklore qui sont ce soir du
passéonéar
àentôoir ça s'arrose mais c'est un peu
triste quand même non pour nous oui
c'est c'est triste quand même on va
quand même perdre 30 % de notre
clientèle facile vous avez passé le bon
moment oui oui oh oui si il y a pas 5
minutes qu'on ne rigole pas il y a
toujours une plaisanterie il y a
toujours une blague il y a toujours une
farce non ça ça après ça va être fini ça
on le connaîtra Paris compte 500000
habitants au tout début du 19e siècle on
est environ à 1 million d'habitants au
milieu du 19e siècle la V compte 2
millions d'habitants alors les faubourgs
ont été intégrés en 1860 mais compte
plus de 2 millions d'habitants au début
du 20e siècle donc il faut faire face à
cette croissance il faut alimenter cette
population qui ne cesse de croître mais
ça suscite des difficultés Paris a du
mal à avoir son ventre au cœur de la
ville si je peux dire et ben je suis
bien heureux de de partir làbord
pourquoi pourquoi parce que si tous les
jours vous passez une demi-heure pour
livrer même pas 200 kg vous passez une
demiheure toutes les routes parce que
tout le
avec voiture làdans pass il y a plus de
Hal il y aura plus de
[Musique]
Paris